- Hello Believe nation,
today we're going to
talk about the seven ways
to have a true impact as an entrepreneur.
- [computerized voice] Nine, eight.
Seven.
- So a theme that comes up a lot
is that if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur
the money can't be the
most important thing
that you're going after.
Money, yes, is important
but it can't be the number one.
If you look at the most successful people
who've made a lot of money,
money may be two or three on the list
but number one there's something
that's more important than money,
and it's having that big impact.
So today I'm going to
talk about the seven ways
to have a true impact as an entrepreneur.
Number one is you need
to find your one word.
I know I wrote a book about it.
I know it sounds a little bit
self-serving, but it's true.
You have to find the
thing that drives you.
You have to have the self-awareness
to know what it is that you stand for.
What is the impact that you want to have?
That's what it's all about.
You can't just say you
want to have an impact
but then not have a plan, right?
You need to know what the
impact is that you want to have.
So for me, I want to spread more belief.
I want people to believe in themselves.
I want people to believe in
the work that they're doing.
I want people to believe
that it's going to work out,
and to keep on hustling,
and keep on trying,
and keep adding that perseverance.
You need to know what you stand for.
You need to know what your one word is
so you can go out and
create an amazing impact
that has clarity and focus and purpose.
Too many people want to have a big impact
but they have no idea what
that big impact looks like.
And so you're never going to get there.
So you need to find your one word.
You need to understand what
your main core value is
and what that impact actually looks like.
Number two is identify your niche.
Once you know what your one word is,
once you know your value
that you're trying to create
out there in the world and spread more of,
you have to figure out where
you're going to attack.
What's the niche that
you're going to attack?
So for me, it's entrepreneurs.
If you want to be the
world's greatest saxophonist,
I can believe in you as
much as I want to, right?
And that can help you.
There'll be some value add there, right?
Having a little injection of
belief is definitely valuable.
But I don't know anything
about being a saxophone player.
I can't give you specific knowledge.
I don't have the context
to be able to help you.
If you want to be an
entrepreneur, I know that.
I've done that.
I am that.
I live that.
I breathe that. I believe that.
I do that every day.
And so finding the niche helps
me have a greater impact.
So just saying believe is great,
and that can help people
believe in themselves,
that's great.
But I can have way more
power and way more impact
and a way greater leverage on people
when I know what I'm talking about.
And so I can do that in the
world of entrepreneurship.
I can do that in the world of salsa.
I can kind of do that in the
world of League of Legends
to some extent,
a little bit in the world of baseball.
Right, in some worlds.
But entrepreneurship is where I reign.
And so you need to understand
what your niche is as well.
What is the audience
that you want to impact
with your message?
Find your niche.
Number three is set a big goal.
You want to have a big impact,
what does that look like?
Again the more specific you can be
the easier it's going
to be to motivate you
to want to go out and do it.
Right, if I say I want to
help a thousand entrepreneurs,
that may not be the most
motivating of goals, right?
I'm not going to crawl
out of bed to say yes,
my life's purpose is to help
a thousand entrepreneurs.
Now, if I was helping them one on one,
if I wanted to invest
in a thousand businesses
and help those companies
really take off, then maybe.
Maybe that is, to make a
thousand angel investments,
that's no joke.
That's a big deal.
But my goal, I want to help
a billion entrepreneurs.
I want to have a big reach.
I want to make a big mark.
I want to have a big impact
on this world when I leave it.
It's not going to happen,
I'm not hitting a billion people tomorrow,
but I'm motivated by that.
I'm driven by that.
I want to go out and accomplish,
I want to do big things with
my message and abilities
to be able to help people.
And so having a big goal that you look at,
that sometimes is scary,
sometimes you look at it
and say I don't know if I can do that.
Those goals are important,
much more than having goals
that are so low that you know you can hit
that don't really drive you forward.
Les Brown was always famous for saying
that most people don't set
goals that are too big and miss,
they set goals that are
too low and they hit.
And then you're complacent.
You don't drive for more.
So having a big goal that
gets you excited and scared
and self doubt sometimes but motivated
is important to be able
to have a big impact.
Number four is then create a plan.
Great to have a goal.
Just like having your one
word, it's great to have that.
Now you need to put the plan in place
for how you're going to
go out and accomplish it.
So you want to go help a billion people.
You want to go make a
thousand angel investments.
Whatever that goal looks like for you.
What's your plan to then
go out and create it?
And you may not have the perfect plan,
and don't worry so much about
creating the perfect plan.
A lot of people get held up here,
in that they work so hard
on making the perfect plan
they never do anything about it.
But you need to have some kind of plan.
You need to study success.
You need to put in action what
you think is going to work,
what logically makes sense,
but you need to start
making the plan to go out
and achieve that big goal
that you set for yourself.
Number five is take consistent action.
This is where a lot of people fall down.
A lot of people have
big dreams, big goals,
but they're not consistent.
They take a little bit of
action, maybe a lot of action,
then they lose their motivation.
They don't do anything for
a week, or a couple days.
Then there's more
action, and then nothing.
It's just constant start
and stop and start and stop
and you never get anywhere.
Right, you're in that car that
is just always on the brakes.
You need consistent
action every single day,
at least 30 to 60 minutes, ideally more
but at least 30 to 60
minutes every single day
on building your idea, on
building your business,
on reaching for that big
impact that you are chasing.
It's important.
You know when my YouTube
channel started taking off?
When I started doing daily content.
I used to be the guy who
was like oh once a week
that's so much to make
one video a week is crazy.
It's so much time, so much effort.
It would be so much
easier to do one a month.
And it's not until you make it a priority,
where you're doing it consistently.
It's for any goal, it's
not just a business thing.
You want to lose weight?
You need to work out consistently.
You need to eat healthy
consistently, right?
You need to have the
plan, that's important,
but you need to stick to the plan.
You've got to do something about it
and not just work out a
little bit and then stop.
Eat healthy for a while and
then eat a bunch of crap.
You're going to be constantly doing this
and never actually making it grow.
You want to have a great relationship?
It's being consistently a
good husband, a good wife,
a good boyfriend, a good girlfriend,
a good father, a good mother.
Right, it's not oh it's your birthday
I'm going to get you flowers.
Or once a month I'm
going to be nice to you.
It's consistent.
You want to have success in any field
you need to take consistent action
and that's one of the things
where a lot of entrepreneurs fall down.
You have great ideas.
You have great ambition.
You have great vision.
You're just not consistent.
You don't do the work every single day.
Number six is build a team.
This is really important
because you need to understand
that to do big things
you can't do it alone.
It's so easy to want to be
the lone wolf entrepreneur,
to feel like you can do everything
better than anybody else,
and people that you've hired
before hasn't worked out
so you're going to shrink back down
and do it all yourself again.
That's what a lot of people do, right?
I'm ready to grow, okay great
I'm going to build a team,
hire somebody, and that
person doesn't work out.
So you think I'm never
going to hire anybody
because that first one didn't work out,
so I'm never going to hire anybody again.
I'm just going to do it all myself.
Right, well did your first
relationship work out?
For some people yes, but most people no.
You probably sucked as a manager.
You probably hired the
wrong person to begin with.
'Cause it's not just hiring for skills,
you need to hire for values.
You probably didn't give them
enough time to train them
and motivate them and encourage them
and understand who they are as a person.
They may have sucked,
but you probably equally sucked as a boss.
You learn through your relationships.
You learn through the hires you have.
You learn through the
business that you create.
And so you need to build a team.
If you want to do something big,
this really is about having a big impact,
you cannot do it by yourself.
You need to build a team.
You need to focus on what is it
that you can bring genius level talent to,
what are you among the best
people in the world at,
and how can you spend as much
time doing that as possible
and have the people on your
team doing everything else.
Now you don't just start day one
with a thousand people on your team.
I get it.
You may be starting by yourself.
That's fine.
But look for as soon as
possible to bring people on,
whether it's an intern.
I started with interns.
I had high school interns.
I had foreign language interns
who wanted to learn
English and came to Canada
and worked for me for free
for three to 12 months.
I had high school interns
who were getting a credit for their class
and worked for me for a school year.
Paid nothing.
I had people on part time gigs.
The first person I hired was part time,
one hour a day to help free up my time.
So you don't have to
jump to hiring somebody
for 50K starting salary full time.
There are ways to get
volunteers, to get partners,
to get people to help
you out, to get interns.
You want to always be
keeping your ears open
for potential talent,
and start building your
team as soon as possible.
And number seven is form
a great environment.
I've talked about this a lot on my videos.
It's probably going to
be a future book of mine
at some point.
Most people's environments just suck.
Your environment keeps you where you are.
We've talked about it how
many times in these videos.
Have you changed your environment?
Have you done it yet?
Is it sinking in yet?
What is on your wall at your
office where you are working?
I don't care if it's in your basement.
I don't care if it's at your mom's house.
I don't care if you have an actual office.
What is on the wall?
Are you inspired going
there to work every day?
What is you morning routine?
Do you do something every
day to get your mindset right
to go out and believe in
that big thing you have?
This video is about helping
you have a big impact.
If you mind is not set properly,
if you don't wake up every day thinking
that you can have a big impact,
if you don't wake up every day motivated
to want to go out and have a big impact,
guess what's going to happen?
You're not going to have a big impact.
'Cause that one afternoon
where you feel motivated
and encouraged, it's not enough.
It's not sustainable.
So think about the times when
you've been most motivated,
most inspired, most dreaming big.
What happened?
Who were you talking to?
What were you consuming?
What were you listening to?
What were you watching?
What was it?
What happened in your life?
And now inject that with
purpose every morning
into your routine so
that you automatically
every day wake up and you get motivation
and you believe in that bigger
impact that you can have.
It's so important guys,
and I've talked about it
over and over and over again,
and I don't see the action happen.
And so I really want you to think about
what's on your walls,
what your morning routine looks like,
what your habits are and make some changes
so that you can start
having the big impact
that you can actually have.
So that's what I got guys.
Those are my seven ways that
you can have a big impact
as an entrepreneur.
I'd love to know what did you think?
What way was your favorite?
What way did you agree with the most
and resonated the most with?
Did I miss something?
Is there an eight, nine, ten
that you guys want to add to the list?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally I want to give a quick
shout out to Luca Avenali.
Luca, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word.
It really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.